hey it's evan i am here in malaysia it
is eight in the morning i'm here for
social media week in malaysia and i want
to take you with me today so this is my
first full day I arrived last night and
this is my hotel room kinda looks like a
rock star came through and trashed the
place it took me 23 hours to get here
and before that I had only slept for
three hours out of 48 so I was exhausted
i came here and basically just crashed
it is super hot here today it is 37
degrees Celsius which is 98.6 fahrenheit
the good news about that is I get to
wear my five toe shoes which I love wine
it's too cold in Toronto minus 22 where
now and I get through on my five toe
socks so I'm excited to go out on the
town with these I bought a few random
snacks to sample out some local things I
don't really know how good ideas are but
we'll see the fish snack cuddle fish
some random chocolate bars these
cow-calf snacks these are actually
really good last night kind of like
crackers barbecue crackers what is Evan
Carmichael read with him I have brought
with me for this trip the King years by
Taylor branch some good reading material
on the flight over I've got my belief
shirts my standard-issue uniform for the
week some clothes and let me show you
the bathroom you got to do the full tour
right now the bathroom this is little
ledge here that I trip over every time I
come into the bathroom so I got to be
careful about this ledge but typical
bathroom in a shower sink toilet all
that fun stuff so I'm going to go get
some breakfast and I'm going to take you
with me on my date today and hopefully
you guys have some fun
so it's breakfast time and here are my
options I've got this whole buffet
congee with condiments Hong Kong style
dimms basically I get the pic whatever I
want here for breakfast not sure what
that is continental drop local fruits i
think i'm going to be full by the time i
go through all this stuff don't know
what this is and a fried egg station and
I might start here so i just finished my
breakfast and I realizes the whole
entire section on the other side that
I'd even show you guys and I'm super
full but the cool thing about this
convention center here where my hotel is
this connected to a convention center
and a mall on this mall I had a chance
to quickly look at yesterday but it's a
humongous it's humongous is crazy so one
of my favorite parts are going to show
you is coming up right here but I never
expected to find in the massive mall
we're going to show you guys right here
it's a skating rink in the middle of
this huge mall there's this giant
skating rink this was packed last night
is a huge party
and it's kind of shocked to see it
anyway one of the things I love to do
when I come to a new country is neat up
with my fans and so I sent an email out
to everybody on my newsletter who's from
Malaysia and said let's go meet up and
I'm going to go to the starbucks is the
starbucks here in the mall that i'm
going to find and meet up with some Evan
Carmichael news that our fans and we'll
see how it go i'm at starbucks are
humongous starbucks and there were
surprised that i ordered a hot drink i
guess these people here when it's
hundred degrees outside there or in the
cold drinks one of the cool things they
have here is sugar syrup we don't get
that in canada and their packages of
sugar are these little pullout things so
I don't think sugar syrups and the taste
too good in my cappuccino so I'm going
to go with some of these sugar packets
so I had a great time at the starbucks I
met up with six different entrepreneurs
from my newsletter list and was awesome
to connect with people local in the city
and now I'm meeting up with a couple
other entrepreneurs we came to the
petronas twin towers so I'm standing
here this is one of the used to be one
of the tallest buildings in the world I
guess it still is one of the tallest
buildings in the world at least we'd eat
all this for a while and there's this
crazy sky bridge across right in the
middle and apparently to get in you've
got to line up at six in the morning and
stand in line for an hour to get tickets
in so I'm just hanging around here on
the outside for a while and we'll see
how
or I start speaking tomorrow i'm here at
the twin towers with Scott and Leon
Scott encourages people to go all in and
he's one of my fellow speakers at the
event Scott tell us about yourself from
Miami I've lived overseas
in all sorts of anything
now I fell into starting a digital
agency in Bangkok last year
we're doing cool stuff I work being did
you
all sorts of media things like that what
do people have to know about going all
in something inside you definitely you
got it you got it just look in the
mirror and say
is the worst case scenario what's the
worst thing that could happen people say
no fail to learn something get yourself
off the brush yourself off either then
I like it and your website people to
learn more or your Twitter account with
you on how do you want people to find
you find me on Twitter it's easier mr.
Scott it so I am coming right from EKG
and i own a
on cost efficient
and use my tour guide for now so we
struck you show me around all right
we're off to enjoy more of Kuala Lumpur
all right I'm leaving the petronas
towers now and I'm on a hop-on hop-off
bus this one is indoor we're gonna try
to get an outdoor one on the way back
and i have a new tour guys have a new
tour guide is helping me along tell us
about yourself I was right the end I'm
volatility and I do creative direction
should i don't think he ever sound
what's your website shall be dub dub dub
another person see any Hitchcock dead
all right she has been on my newsletter
list for a couple years and said come on
out i'll take you around the country or
the city saying so uh here we are next
time take a central market which has a
whole bunch of cultural things devised
we're going to check it out so I went
through Central Market a whole bunch of
stuff to buy but look like a little bit
of a tourist traps decided to keep going
on and I mean
chinatown right now
Scott still with me
although we lost our tour guides they
had meetings we're gonna cook up on
Wednesday so this our indoor Chinatown
moving around what else is the same so I
made it back to my hotel room but I'm
super bummed because i left my phone in
the back of the taxi I was pulling out
my money to pay and we had to get change
and all that and accidentally dropped
the phone on the seat and the guy just
took off and whatever he's up this on
another job but I forgot it in there I
couldn't track him down and I don't know
the license plate I don't know anything
about him and apparently was a
unofficial taxi because I didn't get it
out of scan I just pulled them over at
the side of the street so it's a big
pain because you know I have a lot of
stuff on my phone I you know is the main
way I was checking email and keeping in
touch with with family back home and I
had my laptop so that's good but you
know my password is everything so it's
such a such a pain and I good pictures
that I took today from the phone I'm
hoping that the front desk can pull up a
picture of the license plate from their
closed captioning and then maybe
reported to the police and see what
happens but you know what I'm not I'm
not I'm not holding my breath on this i
don't have a good feeling about it
anyway it was it was a pretty good day
when I'm super bummed about this and not
having the phone for the rest of the
time that I'm here so I'm not sure what
I'm gonna do but they have my info
they're gonna call me at the room if
they get the taxicab number and I'll
keep my fingers crossed that something
good will happen hey guys it is day 2 3
I don't even remember anymore of the
conference I did not find my cell phone
so that it is gone the good karma has
not come back to save me but I had a
great couple of sessions today I ended
up with a huge fight with the bloggers
that I'm excited to see how it turns out
on video and I was talking about salsa
in both my presentations I wanted to go
find the salsa club tonight to go and
dance and
practice and meet the locals and in the
audience was a DJ in the salsa community
and he told me about a club tonight and
he called the DJ who's on tonight and he
said you got to give this guy Evan in
our slot so I'm going to DJ at a salsa
club here in Kuala Lumpur tonight so
it's like what time is it here it is six
in the morning toronto time we just
finished my presentations it's five at
night here and no seven at night here
and now we got to make my playlist so
I'm here got to pick my songs I'm going
to play some some stuff that's good in
Toronto something I like bring a little
Toronto flavor to Kuala Lumpur and I'm
excited so we'll see how things go okay
so I'm in the lobby of the hotel I've
got my Toronto dance salsa family let's
get it in here family shirt on I've got
my playlist ready to go it's going to be
two keys on buzz one bachata went salsa
I'm waiting for DJ salva to come pick me
up and walk to the club okay we are in
the heart of KL walking into the Havana
bar for his own ba salsa bachata night
where I'm going to do some djing and
have some fun here we go
all right I'm inside the club have
turned on my infrared light I'm testing
out this new feature we've got I'm
meeting up with my DJ duck track my
kizomba my favorite DJ duck track here
and right now they're doing a Zumba
lesson get to see here here my fellow co
DJs and I'm DJing with tonight and as
soon as the lessons over we are on and
going live so I'm excited see you soon
right 30 seconds from starting my set
here I'm starting off with DJ duck I'm
real funny story the DJ has this song
already DJ duck is already big news here
in Malaysia so I had to add brown sugar
to the list too hopefully doesn't have
that one so we'll see what happens seven
seconds
here we go time to play
it seems easily
DJ duck
the representing you
tirana dance off to family
here we go
Oh
I
so I made it back to my room is 240 in
the morning stayed up way later than I
thought I would but it was a lot of fun
and the people who are amazing it's
great to see that you know I just said
in that in the conference does anybody
know where it and go salsa dancing
tonight and one of the guys stood up and
family actor's name is Selva I got his
card here Silva from lava media check it
out very cool he came he pick me up took
me to the the club set me up called the
DJ and asked if I could play a set for
them and there's two more things
happening one tomorrow night and won the
next night before i take off on friday
and he wants to pick me up and take me
there the hospitality has been amazing
all the people in this house community
usually people this helps create pretty
pretty fun pretty cool pretty chill and
had a great time meaning the people
there it was interesting that everybody
smokes inside so it's that not used to
that mean for in Canada we kind of band
all that stuff but anyway I need to wash
my clothes and everything because it
smells like smoke but long day fun day
this was great that I had this change
because it puts the lost cell phone a
little bit more in the distant memory so
I'm going to wash up to go to bed and
get ready for a new day tomorrow